it's common for college students to form
bonds that continue outside the
classroom we all know that but at one
Texas University two people share a
connection far beyond campus they've got
a very inspiring message you're never
too young or too old to pursue your
dreams Janet shamlian joins us with
their story
Janet they've got a very special bond
indeed gale their names are Kathy and
Emma they are students at the University
of North Texas both hope to enter the
medical field someday but the link
between these two goes much deeper they
share the same DNA Kathy is Emma's mom
when Emma Earhart walks to class at the
University of North Texas she's the
first to admit this isn't the usual
college experience I mean I really can't
remember a defining moment but all I all
I was thinking was like okay well you
can you can come to college with me but
you're not gonna take classes with me
Kathy does not only am his mom she's her
classmate avere stomach pain missed work
together they tackle the same tough
subjects and a shared dream both want to
become doctors Kathy enrolled after 14
years as a stay-at-home mom you don't
have to do this at 18 you can do this at
30 40 50 60 whatever age you want it's
when you're ready and when you're ready
to give what it takes but that's not the
only extraordinary aspect of this family
affairs emma is a prodigy a junior in
college majoring in biology with a high
school diploma an associate's degree to
her name at just 16 years old I'm
supposed to graduate from here at 17
years old with my bachelor's in biology
and get my MD at 22 I started school at
five as every kid does or she was 14 and
she was stressing over not knowing what
she wanted to be you know like you're 14
you've got time to decide that Kathy
says her daughter's drive gave her the
courage to finally go for a goal of her
own it's gonna take a lot and it is a
huge risk you know who's to say that I
for sure get to go to medical school or
that's
thing doesn't happen what started as one
class together has turned into identical
schedules and for good measure some
healthy competition it'll always be like
oh I'm gonna higher test grade than you
or you know I did better on this and
we're pretty even the challenge extends
beyond Emma and her mom while they're in
school full-time Emma's dad handles home
duties with Emma's two other siblings it
takes a little bit of sacrifice from
everybody everybody has to have the
understanding that the dues have to be
paid for these goals to be met and
everybody's okay with that Jo Earhart is
wowed by the dedication of the women in
his life Kathy's all or nothing so she's
already throwing her chips in on it so
she's in it for the duration and emma is
she's young and you can already tell
that she's passionate about what she
does so I really don't have any worries
about about them achieving their goals
for all the togetherness and shared
dreams Emma hasn't forgotten she is her
mother's daughter she's my friend in
school you know at home yes she's my mom
she'll tell me go unload the dishwasher
but she's not overprotective of me you
know we're both following our own paths
you know but we're doing it together
and I think it's really it's really
special you know special indeed and how
are these two doing in school well it's
something of a competition emma has a
3.7 grade average her mom has a 3.79
more important than that they're on this
journey together they're both chasing a
dream this is a great family but I'll
tell you this could never happen in my
house beautiful family Jana good to see
at the table thank you very much